think about let's go back
really big because i know this is you're
so good
yeah in the very so long ago in
evolution we had these genes
and you they wanted to make copies of
themselves that's really all they cared
about
so they some gene said hey i'm going to
build a brain on this body i'm in so
that i can get better at making copies
of myself yes
and then they decided for their benefit
to get copied more to align your brain's
incentives with their incentives so it
didn't want
you to starve to death so it gave you an
incentive to eat
and it it wanted you to make copies of
of the genes
so it gave you incentive to fall in love
and
[Music]
do all sorts of naughty things to make
copies of it
of itself right yeah so that was
successful value alignment done
on the genes they created something more
intelligent than themselves but they
made sure to try to align the values
but then something went a little bit raw
against the
idea of what the genes wanted because a
lot of humans discovered hey you know
yeah we really like this
business about sex that the genes have
made us enjoy
but we don't want to have babies right
now yeah so we're going to hack the
genes
and use birth control and i really feel
like drinking a coca-cola right now but
i don't want to get a pot belly so i'm
going to drink diet coke you know
we have all these things we've figured
out because we're smarter than the genes
how we can actually subvert
their intentions so it's not surprising
that
we humans now when we're in the role of
these genes creating other non-human
entities with a lot of power
have to face the same exact challenge
how do we make other powerful entities
have incentives that are aligned with
ours
and that so they won't hack them
you